>>Narrator: They are dueling
with robots in Florida,
and study microorganisms in New York,
designing future schools in Seattle,
and racing electric cars in Hawaii.
All across the country
students are being called upon
to show what they know in
challenging tests of their abilities.
>>Man: Here we go!
The national championship
on the line.
>>Narrator: These are the fun tests.
>>Teacher: Today we're going to
take SAT I, the reasoning test.
>>Narrator: But today's students face
other kinds of exams and their score
on one of them can
determine their future.
With pressures mounting
and stakes on the rise,
some educators believe we are
asking the wrong questions
with standardized tests.
>>Linda: There's an irony in
testing in American schools.
We probably have kids who are the
most tested and under examined
of any kids in the world.
Take New York State for example.
Even before they get to
the Regents examinations,
students will have taken
20 batteries of tests
over the course of
their school careers.
So there are thousands and thousands
of hours spent on taking these tests
and preparing for these tests
which give very little indication
of what kids can actually
do in real-world situations.
>>Howard: People may be good test
takers but once you leave the world
of testing you have
to think for yourself
because the world doesn't
come organized in four choices
with the fourth one being
"None of the above".
>>Hugh: As I was mulling all these
issues about the SAT I was struck
by the fact that there are all
sorts of other attributes like drive
and grit and determination,
ability to problem-solve,
communication skills,
leadership skills.
These intangibles that
were critically important.
>>Student: So we could get 120
points just for getting our robots
in the end zone without
scoring any balls...
>>Hugh: And that by virtue of
excessive reliance on SAT scores,
you're ruling out large numbers
of youngsters of all races
and all complexions who may not
have stratospheric SAT scores,
but who have these other
kinds of attributes
that experience shows contribute to
high-level success in the real world.
>>Eeva: Is this what the
science wing would look like?
>>Narrator: Teachers like Eeva Reeder
believe that measuring performance
on projects is a better way
to gauge a student's potential
for real world success.
>>Student: Open inviting area...
>>Narrator: So instead of
memorizing geometrical abstractions,
her students spend the last six weeks
of their sophomore year designing
schools for the year 2050.
>>Student: Why not have the
whole side like wall open,
be glass facing the water.
>>Eeva: To assess a student's
deep understanding of a subject
and their ability to apply a
concept you cannot test those kinds
of abilities through a traditional
paper and pencil kind of assessment.
It has to be what we call a
performance-based assessment
and that's why I do these projects
because the project
requires these students
to create products or performances.
>>Student: In the beginning
we decided to start
with the floor plans and the designs.
Our school has one main building.
>>Eeva: I have to come up with
ways to assess those products
and performances so I look
at the site plan and look
at the perspective drawing.
I read the proposal.
And I have a scoring guide
developed for each one of those.
But I think that the most powerful
assessment for this project is
that provided by the architects.
>>Man: When I first saw
your drawings I thought
to myself this is a
real consistent idea.
>>Narrator: While performance-based
assessment requires a significant
investment of time and energy,
proponents insist it
is time well spent.
>>Linda: The students have
to develop the performances.
The teachers have to evaluate them.
But the time is not lost
to teaching and learning.
The time is teaching and learning.
Because the actual conduct of the
assessment is a learning experience
for the students as
well as the teacher.
It informs teaching.
It actually gives teachers feedback
immediately about what they need
to do to meet students' needs so
it's actually productive time.
>>Narrator: The Urban Academy in New
York City is part of a consortium
of 32 schools that has rejected
tests like the state's Regents exam
and replaced it with a series
of performance assessments.
>>This thesis isn't clear.
It seems as though he jumps from-
>>Ann: We're very interested in
students developing certain skills.
We re interested in them
developing an ability to work
with multiple perspectives to be able
to analyze evidence,
to be able to critique.
>>We want them to be able to
take text and talk about it,
be able to understand to
compare different texts
and to read whole books, not
just little snippets of books.
And we've set them up
with an external assessor.
Someone who has agreed to spend an
hour with that student who has agreed
to read the book, and who then sites
sown with that student and discusses
that book for 45 minutes or an hour.
>>Student: She's going
to him to see whether
or not he saw what she had done.
>>Right.
>>Ann: What we're really trying
to see is can that student take
that reading and go and talk
to somebody they don't know,
a perfect stranger, about the book
and have a conversation about it.
That's one way that we can tell
whether a student is ready to go on
and do college-level work.
>>Student: Is that about a 26.
How come it's so low?
>>Narrator: Critics of
performance-based assessment worry
that if students are
free to pursue projects
of their choice standards
will suffer.
But some assessment experts say
that independent study projects
should meet the highest standards.
>>Grant: What we have to
do is realize that even
if we give the kid free reign to do
really cool projects it's still got
to fit within the context of some
objectives and some standards
and some criteria that
we bring to it.
>>Student: For those of you
who aren't sure what
[inaudible] pools are, they're-
>>Grant: So that we can say
by the end I have evidence,
I can make the case that you learn
something substantial and significant
that relates to school objectives.
>>Teacher: As far as listening
and speaking and writing,
you're making steady progress.
>>Narrator: One school the Key
Learning Community in Indianapolis
in Indiana has a clear
and unique objective.
Established in 1987 the school
is dedicated to the cultivation
of multiple intelligences and to
developing new methods of assessment.
>>Teacher: Ours represent that
these are his strength areas
and also anytime that
you see a the shape
of a triangle those also
represent the strengths.
>>Pat: We're interesting in
how students apply knowledge
and so students are required
through their high school
to do major projects each semester.
At the end of high school they
should have eight major projects
that they would have developed
and all of this is put together
on a multimedia portfolio to document
what it is they're capable of doing.
>>Student: I've been working with
the Egyptians because they had
so many symbols and
hieroglyphics and things like that.
>>Pat: I think that what we're doing
here is going to be needed very soon
because people are going to realize
how shortsighted all of this effort
on standardized tests is.
It's going to crash.
It has crashed in the past.
It will crash and people will
need something else to replace it
and maybe we might
help in that effort.
>>Narrator: For schools that are
challenging the high-stakes testing
movement, the goal is to put less
emphasis on cramming, drills,
and test taking strategies and
focus on in-depth learning.
>>Ann: I'm all for high standards.
I don't know of anybody
who is for low standards.
The question is do we get
at what we're saying we want
using the tests to drive this?
That's the real crux of it and
I would argue that we don't.
>>Grant: A lot of teachers
and administrators
in their understandable concern
about these high-stakes tests are
making a mistake when they say "Teach
to the test, teach to the test.
That's what we have to do."
There's no evidence to show that you
raise test scores by teaching worse.
There's no evidence to
show that when you teach
for an in-depth robust performance
where you have high-quality
local assessment
that your test scores suffer.
In fact the evidence
is to the contrary.
High quality local assessment is
what we need to pay attention to.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org.